speaking of morality and values and
hypocrisy alabama Governor the alabama
Governor Robert Bentley has resigned as
governor and has pled guilty to two
charges of campaign violation campaign
contribution violations this is all
connected to Pat his affair his alleged
affair with his former aide Rebecca
Mason so according to his plea deal he
would have to resign immediately and
leave public life plead guilty to two
campaign violations converting campaign
contributions for personal gain and
failing to report campaign contributions
he would have to serve one year
probation perform 100 hours of unpaid
community service and repaid almost nine
thousand dollars in campaign a fund that
he spent for the legal fees of his
alleged mistress Rebecca Mason finally
he'd have to forfeit all the money in
his campaign account which is about
thirty six thousand dollars almost
thirty seven thousand dollars this is
being reported by John Archibald of
Alabama calm he goes into some great
reporting here but the hypocrisy and the
scale of this is is staggering when you
consider the positions on traditional
family values that Republicans always
forward right and the sex scandal is one
thing obviously it's hypocritical but i
don't think that alone should cost him
his job it's certainly going to have a
negative effect on his marriage and
uncle deacon and a baptist church so i'm
sure that it's not going to play very
well the misuse of campaign funds i
think is a much worse crime there ya
know obviously and that's actually where
articles of impeachment were being drawn
by the House Judiciary Committee on this
past week I mean it's been moving and
progressing his direction where he was
going to be in peach if he didn't step
down and also the charges for campaign
infractions campaign finance and
fractions were based on two charges that
could have been felonies so he actually
really could have spent some significant
amount of time in all in jail had he not
resigned so you're right the sexual
scandal notwithstanding the hypocrisy it
really should not be enough to scuttle
him but his campaign finance violations
actually led to his arrest he
surrendered himself and here is a
mugshot
for posterity sake Robert of Robert
Julian Bentley former governor of
alabama stepping down in disgrace yeah
this is conservative hypocrisy 101 it's
always the politicians who are most
vehement lee anti-gay that turned out to
be gay themselves and in this case it's
the conservatives who are Family Values
types who yes turn out to be having
affairs and skeletons in their closet
yeah and we see this all the time it's
not surprising but it is it is
newsworthy because you have a governor
actually being held accountable for his
violations albeit not the full extent of
his violations he's only going to
probably serve when your probation but
at least he's no longer in office as a
result of his campaign finance
violations